This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Many of us spend enormous amounts of time asking ourselves what other people think of us. Do they notice our flaws? Are they mocking us behind our backs? Do they think we're boring? It turns out that the way we imagine we're being seen is often spectacularly wrong. In our episode last week, we looked at how we spend a lot of time trying to read other people's minds and how we often misinterpret their intentions. Today we continue our series, Mind Reading 2.0. We explore how social illusions shape our relationships at home and in the workplace.
这里是《隐秘大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。我们许多人花大量时间去琢磨别人是怎么看我们的。他们会注意到我们的缺点吗？他们在背后嘲笑我们吗？他们觉得我们很无聊吗？事实证明，我们想象自己被看待的方式往往错得离谱。在上一期的节目中，我们探讨了我们如何花大量时间去揣摩别人的心思，以及我们又是如何经常误解他们的意图。今天我们继续“读心术2.0”系列节目。我们将探讨社交错觉是如何塑造我们家庭和职场中的人际关系的。
There's just so many things that we, uh, mistakes that we fall into, these sort of social traps that lead us to be a lot more pessimistic about our social lives than kind of reality warrants. How to see the world with greater clarity and walk with greater confidence. This week on Hidden Brain. When we talk to other people, we are often trying to figure them out, but we also try to guess what the other person thinks of us. We worry how am I coming across? Am I flaws on prominent display? Or does this person think I'm cool? Most of us think we are good judges of our social interactions
我们常常会陷入许许多多的错误之中，也就是那种让我们对社交生活的悲观程度远远超过现实情况所需的社交陷阱。如何更清晰地看清这个世界，并带着更多的自信前行。本周《隐秘大脑》。当我们与他人交谈时，我们常常试图看透他们，但我们也会试着去猜对方是怎么看我们的。我们担心：我给人的印象怎么样？我的缺点是不是特别显眼？这个人觉得我很酷吗？我们大多数人都认为自己很擅长评判自己的社交互动，
that we can tell if other people like us. But new research suggests this is often not the case. Our perceptions of our social interactions are often distorted. At the University of Pennsylvania's Wharton School, psychologists Erica Boothby studies these distortions and what we can do about them. Erica Boothby, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me. I'd like to take you back to the start of your interest in this topic, Erica. You were in grad school and sitting at a cafe with a friend, and you'd also planned to meet a potential collaborator
认为自己能看出别人是否喜欢自己。但新的研究表明，情况往往并非如此。我们对社交互动的主观感受常常是扭曲的。在宾夕法尼亚大学沃顿商学院，心理学家埃里卡·布思比一直在研究这些扭曲现象以及我们能做些什么。埃里卡·布思比，欢迎来到《隐秘大脑》。谢谢邀请我来。埃里卡，我想带你回到你对这个话题产生兴趣的最初。当时你在读研究生，和朋友坐在一家咖啡馆里，你们还计划在咖啡馆里见一位潜在的合作者。
at the cafe. She showed up and you went over and started chatting. What happened next? Yeah, so I was at a cafe just down the street from my apartment called Cafe Romeo. And I worked there a lot with my partner who's also a psychologist, and I went and left him, went to a couple of tables down where I was talking to this person who I thought we might
她出现了，你走过去开始聊天。接下来发生了什么？嗯，当时我在离我公寓不远的一家名叫“罗密欧咖啡馆”的咖啡馆里。我和我的伴侣经常在那里工作，他也是一名心理学家。我离开他，走到几张桌子外，和这个人谈话，我当时觉得我们可能会
launch a collaboration. And I really got the sense from our conversation that she was a very interesting person and had a lot of interesting ideas. But as I was talking to my partner and debriefing him on how it had gone, I said I really doubted that she would want to work with me. Because our conversation hadn't really gone all that well.
展开合作。从我们的谈话中，我真切地感觉到她是一个非常有趣的人，有许多很有意思的想法。但当我回到伴侣身边，向他汇报进展时，我说我真的很怀疑她是否愿意和我合作。因为我们的谈话其实并没有那么顺利。
I had expected her to ask me about kind of one stream of research. She instead took the conversation in a totally different direction and I was unprepared. And then my partner got kind of a sheepish look on his face and he admitted that he'd actually been eavesdropping a little. But the good news was, is that he thought we had really hit it off and that I'd come off really well in the conversation. And so we had these wildly different perspectives on what had happened. So as psychologists, this guy was thinking, who was right in this case, right? Who had a better read on the situation?
我本期望她问我关于某一个研究方向的问题，但她却把谈话引向了一个完全不同的方向，这让我毫无准备。接着，我的伴侣脸上露出一副有点害羞的表情，他承认其实他刚才稍微偷听了一下。但好消息是，他觉得我们俩其实非常投缘，而且我在谈话中表现得非常好。因此，对于刚才发生的事情，我们有着截然不同的看法。所以作为心理学家，这家伙就在想，这种情况下到底谁是对的呢？究竟谁对形势的把握更准确？
Erica asked herself, whether the incident reveals something not just about her, but something about people in general. It was very curious that there was this kind of wide gap it seemed between what my partner had observed from the outside and what I had felt as someone on the inside of the conversation. And it got us thinking there must be some interesting psychology here.
埃里卡开始自问，这件事是不是不仅反映了她自己，也反映了人们的某种普遍心理。很奇怪的是，我这个身处对话之中的局内人所感受到的情况，和我的伴侣作为局外人所观察到的情况之间，似乎存在着如此巨大的鸿沟。这让我们开始思考，这里面一定存在着某些有趣的心理学原理。
To test this, Erica teamed up with some researchers from the United Kingdom who were organizing personal development workshops where lots of strangers meet one another. And what we like is that this was outside of the lab, which is where we normally run studies, and so we could see how this kind of happens in the real world. And we found that people believed their conversation partners were more interesting than they thought
为了检验这一点，埃里卡与来自英国的研究人员合作，他们当时正在组织个人发展工作坊，许多陌生人会在那里相聚。我们喜欢的是，这是在实验室之外进行的——我们通常是在实验室里开展研究，这样我们就能看到这种现象在现实世界中是如何发生的。我们发现，人们认为他们的谈话对象比他们想象的更有趣，
their conversation partners found them. Which is, of course, exactly what you had felt in the cafe, which is that you thought the conversation went well, but you believe that your potential collaborator would not have found it as interesting. Exactly. In the case of the work when I was in Cafe Romeo having this conversation,
而他们的谈话对象对他们的看法也是如此。这当然就是你在咖啡馆里曾感受到的那种情况，也就是你觉得谈话进行得很顺利，但你认为你的潜在合作者可能并不觉得这有多有趣。完全正确。当我在罗密欧咖啡馆进行那次谈话时，
we didn't know exactly what the other person, the potential collaborator thought of me. We just knew what my partner had observed. And so what's interesting is that, as we continue to pursue this and bringing this into experimental paradigms, we could really test people's perceptions against reality. The experiment that you conducted with the volunteers who thought they were part of a personal development workshop, it revealed to you in some ways that the experience that
我们并不知道对方——也就是那位潜在合作者——对我的真实看法。我们只知道我伴侣观察到的情况。因此有趣的是，随着我们继续深入研究，并将其引入实验范式中，我们就可以真正用现实来检验人们的感知。你和那些自认为是个人发展工作坊成员的志愿者一起进行的实验在某种程度上向你表明，你的经历
you had was not unique. And it wasn't just that one person thinks that they enjoyed the conversation but the other person did not, but that both people enjoyed the conversation, but both believed that the other would be less into the conversation. You came up with a term for this phenomenon. What was that term, Erica? This is the Liking Gap. And the Liking Gap is the phenomenon. Most commonly this happens among people
并不是孤立的。不仅不是一个人觉得谈话愉快而另一个人觉得不愉快，而是双方都觉得谈话很愉快，但两人的共同信念却是对方其实没那么投入。你为这种现象起了一个术语。埃里卡，那是什么术语？这就是“喜爱鸿沟”（The Liking Gap）。“喜爱鸿沟”就是这样一种现象。这种情况最常见于初次相识的人之间。
who are getting acquainted for the first time. And so when you're meeting someone new, you're having that initial conversation. Afterward, you reflect on how it went. And most often, people actually enjoy these initial conversations and like the other person quite a bit, but they tend to underestimate how much the other person likes them and enjoy their conversation.
因此，当你结识新朋友时，你会进行那次初步交谈。事后，你会回顾交谈的进展。大多数情况下，人们其实挺享受这些初次交谈的，并且对对方也颇有好感，但他们往往会低估对方到底有多喜欢自己、有多享受与他们的交谈。
You ran a similar experiment with first-year college students who were getting to know one another as potential dorm mates. What happened in that experiment? So in that case, we were actually curious to see whether we would see a liking gap as people increasingly get to know each other over time. And so we recruited college roommates who had just landed at school for the first time in September and they get thrown into room with someone they've never met before. And a huge question for them is whether the other person is going to like them and that really matters to them. And so we tracked these new roommates at five different time points
你对作为潜在室友开始互相了解的大一新生做过一个类似的实验。那个实验中发生了什么？所以在那个案例中，我们其实很好奇，随着时间的推移，当人们越来越熟悉彼此后，我们是否还能看到“喜爱鸿沟”的存在。于是，我们在9月份刚到学校报到的一年期大学室友中招募了志愿者，他们被随机安排和从未见过面的人住进同一个宿舍。对他们来说，一个巨大的问题就是对方是否会喜欢自己，这让他们非常在意。因此，我们在9月到5月期间的五个不同时间点对这些新室友进行了追踪调查。
between September and May. We asked them how much they liked their roommates and how much they thought their roommates liked them. And what we found there was that people actually underestimated how much they were made like them for several months, like through the fall, into the spring, and finally by the end of the year, we did see that the liking gap went away. But you also took this idea and built on it to suggest that it might be that this is not the only place in which we misjudge how other people think of us and how the interaction is going.
我们询问他们有多喜欢自己的室友，以及他们认为室友有多喜欢自己。我们在那里的发现是，在几个月的时间里，比如整个秋季一直到春季，人们其实都低估了室友对他们的喜爱程度；最后到了年底，我们确实发现“喜爱鸿沟”消失了。但你也以此为基础进一步提出，这可能并不是我们对“别人如何看待我们”以及“互动进展如何”产生误判的唯一地方。
Talk about how and when you decided that this was not just about the lacking gap, but about a much larger set of phenomena that you eventually came to describe as social illusions. Yeah, so we're constantly trying to figure out what other people think of us. And I have sort of taken this puzzle and zoomed in on several different facets of it. And I think there's just so many things that we, uh, mistakes that we fall into, these sort of social traps that lead us to be a lot more pessimistic about our social lives than kind of reality warrants. Hmm. I want to talk later in the episode about ways
谈谈你是如何以及何时决定这不仅仅关乎喜爱鸿沟，而是关乎一套更大得多的现象，你最终将其描述为社交错觉的？是的，所以我们一直在试图弄清楚别人是怎么看我们的。我把这个谜题拿来，放大了它的几个不同侧面。我觉得我们陷入的错误、那种把我们引向对自己的社交生活比现实允许的要悲观得多的社交陷阱，实在是有太多太多了。嗯。我想在节目后面的部分谈谈我们如何才能克服对人际关系认知的这些扭曲。但我想要看看这些扭曲有多普遍。我想到了电影《当哈利遇上莎莉》，里面有一个经典场景：哈利和莎莉终于走到了一起，然后分别跟各自的朋友聊起过程怎么样。嗨，糟透了。你是怎么脱身的？
we can get past some of these distortions in our perceptions of our social relationships. But I want to look at how common these distortions are. I'm thinking about the movie when Harry Met Sally, there's this classic scene when Harry and Sally finally get together, and then have separate conversations with friends about how it went. Hi, the worst. How did you get out of that?
他直接消失了。我感觉太糟糕了。我太尴尬了。我不怪他。这太可怕了。我觉得我快感冒了。不，要是能成的话其实挺好的，但没成。我待会儿打给你，好吗？
He just disappeared. I feel so bad. I'm so embarrassed. I don't blame him. That's horrible. I think I'm catching a cold. No, it would have been great if it worked out, but it didn't. I'll call you later, okay?
好的，拜拜。拜。拜。所以，你知道的，埃里卡，当我听完你的研究后再听到这段录音时，我感到震惊的是，我们花在试图理解这些社交互动上的时间和精力是如此之多，而我们弄错的时候又是多么频繁。我太喜欢这个了。这是一个很好的例子，说明了我们如何不向彼此坦白我们的想法和感受。相反，我们往往把这些表达给其他人。对吧？而这有助于让这些错觉继续存活。是的。有没有可能，其中的某些社交错觉，实际上
Okay, bye. Bye. Bye. So, you know, when I hear that clip after reading your work, Erica, I'm struck by how much time and effort we put into trying to understand these social interactions and how often we get things wrong. I love that. It's a great example of how we don't tell each other the things that we're thinking and that we feel. We express them instead oftentimes to other people. Right? And this helps keep these illusions alive. Yeah. Is it possible that some of these social illusions, in fact,
在高压、高风险的情况下（比如约会）会被放大？我的意思是，比如这些浪漫的爱情情境，会不会让“喜爱鸿沟”变得异常强烈？是的，我的意思是，我认为任何时候，只要我们非常非常在意别人怎么看我们，我们就会给自己施加额外的压力，要求自己表现出最高水平。因此，在那些时刻，我们将对自己的不足表现得高度敏感——比如那些我们表现得不如预期、或者说了不该说的话、又或者没能说出想说的话的时刻。因此，在我们极度在意自己给别人的印象的程度上，这些缺点对我们来说会格外显眼。我们已经探讨了社交错觉的一个重要维度。让我们来看另一个。同样，让我们回到你的研究生时代。有一段时间，你对于自己是否显得足够聪明、是否足够优秀以留在研究生院感到非常自我意识过剩。
are amplified during high pressure, high stake situations like dating? I mean, can these romantic situations, for example, put the liking gap on steroids? Yeah, I mean, I think anytime where we really, really care about what someone else thinks of us, we're going to put extra pressure on ourselves to perform at the highest level. And so in those moments, we're going to be hyper aware of the ways that we're falling
有一次，你在酒吧里和几个朋友聊天，谈话转向了大家都在追的电视节目。对吧。大家当时都还处在刚认识的初期阶段。直到今天，我依然不知道为什么我会做出那样的回答。但不管出于什么原因，我说我看了《单身汉》。让女人们上场吧！
short of the way that we wish we behaved or the things we wish we said or hadn't said. And so those are going to be extra salient to us to the extent that we care a lot about how we're coming off. So we've looked at one important dimension of social illusions. Let's look at another. And again, let's go back to your time in graduate school. At one point, you were really self-conscious about appearing smart enough and good enough to being grad school.
克莱顿就像是完美先生。正如日常对话那样，在那之后不久，话题就自然而然地转到了另一个主题上。但那天晚些时候，我脑子里一直不断地回放那个时刻，反复咀嚼。为了我们大家！哦！等等，她好像在说，我要克制一下。
And one time, you were talking with some friends at a bar, and the conversation turned to the TV shows that people were watching. Right. Everyone was still kind of in the earliest ages getting to know one another. And to this day, I still don't know why this was my response. But for whatever reason, I said I watched the Bachelor. Bring on the women!
因为我简直不敢相信。那一档节目竟然就是我和一群我真的很想留下好印象的人在一起时脱口而出的节目。你知道我们在这儿，大块头。我觉得类似的事情一直在我们身上发生：琐碎的事情发生了，我们说了或做了某些事，然后我们在接下来的几个小时甚至几星期里
Clayton's like the whole package. As conversations do, it kind of just drifted to another topic pretty quickly after that. But later that night, I kept kind of coming back to that moment and just replaying it in my head. For all of us! Oh! Wait, she's like, I'm gonna hold back.
对此耿耿于怀，琢磨着别人是怎么看我们的，内心饱受煎熬。完全正确。我们的思想基本上彻底失控了。如果我当时那样做了呢？如果我当时谈论的是我看过的《国家地理》节目呢？我当时怎么会说那个？如果我谈论的是你看得很入迷的肯·伯恩斯纪录片呢？没错。然后我们会想，你知道的，比如，“天哪，他们肯定会因为这个而评判我，”对吧？
Because I just couldn't believe it. That was the show that I came up with when I was with a bunch of people that I really wanted to impress. You know we're here, big boy. And I feel like something like this happens to us all the time, that trivial things happen, we say or do things, and then we perseverate on this for hours or sometimes for weeks
我说了错话。这种情况下结果如何呢？你有没有发现，研究生院的朋友们是否因为你看了《单身汉》而对你另眼相看？所以，是的，几天后我竟然偶遇了当时参与那次对话的人，她问我愿不愿意加入她们的行列，因为那是她们每周一起看《单身汉》的朋友圈。《单身汉》回归了。所以显然我并没有自己想象的那么孤单。如我所想的那样孤单。我们已经讨论了一些你所研究的社交错觉是如何在与陌生人、熟人甚至刚开始互相了解的人的互动中产生的。但社交错觉也会影响长期的关系。我想放一段《贝莱尔的鲜王子》中的剪辑，威尔·史密斯扮演的角色担心他的叔叔——过去几年一直照顾他的人——对他的看法很差。我只是不想让你觉得我还和刚搬来时一样是个笨头笨脑的小孩。你怎么会这么想？
afterwards, wondering what people thought of us and eating ourselves up on the inside. Exactly. Our thoughts basically just run wild. What if I had done it? What if I had talked about the National Geographic show I watched instead? Why did I on that? What if I had talked about the National Geographic show I watched instead? Like, why did I say that? She'd have talked about the Ken Burns documentaries that you're a big fan of. Exactly. And then we think, you know, like, oh god, they're just judging me for that, right?
我刚才就是这么想的。看看你。你正独立搬出去住。你一年内就能大学毕业。你正在成为一个男人。一个让我感到无比骄傲的男人。我只是不想让你对我的最后印象比最初的还要糟糕。你根本不知道我对你的第一印象是什么。
I said the wrong thing. And what happened in this case? Did you ever discover whether your friends in graduate school thought less of you because you watched the Bachelor? So, yeah, a few days later I actually ran into someone who was at that conversation and she asked me if I wanted to join her as my friends who watched the Bachelor together every week. The Bachelor's back. So clearly I wasn't as alone as I thought. as alone as I thought. We've talked a bit about how some of the social illusions that you study arise in interactions with people who are strangers or acquaintances or even people who are starting to get to
我记得一个充满无限潜力的孩子。而现在我看到的是一个即将兑现自己潜力的人。埃里卡，你能谈谈这个吗？对某人的熟悉并不自动意味着这些社交错觉就会消失。对吧。我认为对于我们不了解的人来说，这些错觉会更加极端，你知道，很大程度上仅仅是因为我们不知道他们是怎么想的，
know one another. But social illusions can also affect long-standing relationships. I want to play you a clip from the Fresh prince of Belair, our Will Smith's character is Wari that is uncle, who has been taking care of him for the past several years, thinks poorly of him. I just don't want you to think that I'm this same stupid kid I was when I first moved out here. How could you possibly believe it?
或者他们会因为什么样的事情去评判别人。但即使我们与某人的关系变得更亲密了，这也并非一种保证，因为我们无法触及那些人脑海中的每一个想法。因此，即使你和某人的关系变得更亲密了，依然存在着某种鸿沟。有些社交错觉带来的后果并不总是很严重。有时它们可能会很有趣。
That's what I'd be thinking. Look at you. You're moving out on your own. You're going to finish college in a year. You're becoming a man. Man, I'm damn proud of. I just don't want your last memory of me to be no better than the first one. You have no idea what my first memory of you is.
亚当·马斯特里亚尼（Adam Mastriani）和他的同事最近发表了一项研究，探讨人们何时希望对话结束。他们发现，当一个人想结束谈话时，对话几乎从来不会在那时结束；而当另一个人想结束时，它同样也不会在那时结束。对话的持续时间有时比任何一方希望的都要短，有时又比任何一方希望的要长得多。我觉得这说明了这样一个鸿沟：
I remember a kid loaded with all the potential in the world. And now I see a person on the verge of realizing their potential. Can you talk about this a moment, Erika? Familiarity with someone doesn't automatically mean that these social illusions disappear. Right. I think they are more extreme for people we do not know, you know, in large part just because we don't know how they think
即我们认为对话进展得怎么样，与我们认为对方对对话有何看法之间存在差距。是的，完全正确。我非常喜欢这项研究。我认为，这同样是因为我们没有明确告诉彼此我们想要什么。我们依赖了大量的隐性暗示，
or what kinds of things they judge people for. But even as we get closer to people, it's not a guarantee because we don't have access to every single thing that those people think. And so we do, there is kind of a gap. There's still even as you get closer to someone. So the consequences of some of these social illusions are not always serious. Sometimes they can be funny.
许多社交生活和对话就是这样运作的。因此，我们往往倾向于仅仅寄希望于自己能够理解对方的需求。而当他们可能想要结束对话时，我们就顺水推舟地让他们离开。对吧。但我们往往会弄错。
Adam Mastriani and his colleagues recently published a study looking at when people want conversations to end. And they found that conversations almost never end when a person wants them to end, and they don't end when a person b wants them to end either. Conversations sometimes run shorter than either party wants, and sometimes they run much longer than either party wants. And I feel like the speak to the gap
是的。在那篇论文中，研究人员写道，人类往往无法解决这些问题，因为解决这些问题需要人们分享他们通常对彼此隐瞒的信息。所以问题不仅仅在于我们没有感知到事物，而在于我们正在积极地隐瞒那些实际上能让对方得出正确结论的信息。
between how we think a conversation is going, and what we think the other person thinks about the conversation. Yeah, exactly. I love that work. And I think it's, again, because we aren't explicit with each other about what we want. We rely on a lot of implicit cues,
没错，这就是个问题。我的意思是，深入思考这些事情确实让我意识到，如果我们能在某些事情上更明确一些，那将会有所帮助，你知道，我知道我们并不总是想把底牌全盘托出，但也许，比如我研究过的这些大学室友，如果他们能早一点、在几个月前就把底牌稍微亮出来一点，也许事情就会变得更清晰一些。但我认为我们在很多方面都防备心很重。在面对被拒绝或可能被拒绝的情况时，我们的风险厌恶倾向非常高。这真正向我们展示了注意力的力量以及我们所关注的焦点。如果我们关注的是对自身的负面想法，并将这些想法投射到别人身上，那这种负面情绪就会被无限放大，并往往会掩盖那些实际上也可能是真的其他事情。
and that's how a lot of social life and a lot of conversation operates. So I think that we tend to just sort of hope that we're able to understand what the other person wants. And when they might want to get out of the conversation, then we gently let them go. Right. But we often get that wrong.
甚至在新冠疫情爆发之前，社会科学家就在警告全球性的孤独流行病。社交隔离会加剧抑郁、焦虑和药物滥用。长期的孤独会增加患心脏病和其他疾病的风险。一个解决方案是不是去意识到，其实我们大多数人拥有的朋友比我们自己意识到的要多？稍后回来，我们将探讨大脑中那些让我们难以清晰看待社交互动的机制，以及我们如何才能做得更好。您正在收听的是《隐秘大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这里是《隐秘大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。
Yeah. In that paper, the researchers write that humans are often unable to solve these problems because solving these problems requires people to share information that they normally keep from each other. So the problem is not just that we're know, we're not perceiving things, but we're actively hiding the information that would allow the other person, in fact,
我们许多人度过了一个又一个不眠之夜，担心别人是怎么看我们的。但在别人眼中我们对自己的倒影往往是扭曲的。我们误读了互动，过度沉溺于自身的 insecurities（不安全感）。我们未能注意到别人实际是怎么看我们的。埃里卡·布思比和她的同事研究了这些社交错觉背后的心理机制。埃里卡，你曾作为高中交换生在意大利生活过。你会说意大利语吗？所以在我到那里之前，我其实并不会说意大利语。我只是参加了一个非常基础的意大利语速成班，基本上是为了旅行准备的。所以我学到了一些诸如如何数到10之类的东西。
to draw the right conclusions. Right, that's a problem. I mean, I think thinking about these things a lot does make me, you know, aware that it would help if we could be more explicit about some things, you know, I know that we don't always want to play our hand fully, but maybe if these college roommates that I studied for example had played their hands just a little sooner, a few months before, maybe things would have been a little bit clearer
我可以说我的名字叫埃里卡。我是美国人。也许还有其他一些东西。这就是我全部的水平了。而且那是全沉浸式环境。所以我住在意大利人的家里，上的是意大利的高中。我当时感觉非常尴尬，因为我无法真正与人进行对话。
to people. But I think we're very guarded in a lot of ways. We're very risk-averse when it comes to getting rejected or the possibility of rejection. And it really shows us as the power of our attention and what we're focused on. And if we are focused on the negative thoughts about ourselves that we're projecting onto other people, that looms really large and it tends to obscure other things that might actually also be true.
因此，甚至在家里和寄宿家庭一起坐在餐桌旁时，他们想了解我的一天过得怎么样。我很想能够告诉他们，但我们就是做不到。这真的非常具有挑战性。在学校里，我和同学们也是如此。他们会在课间站在一起聊天。
Even before the COVID pandemic, social scientists were warning about a global epidemic of loneliness. Social isolation contributes to depression, anxiety, and drug abuse. Chronic loneliness increases the risk of heart disease and other illnesses. Is one solution to see that many of us actually have more friends than we realize? When we come back, the mechanisms in the mind that make it difficult for us to see our social interactions clearly and how we can do better. You are listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta.
而我就会有些尴尬地站在那里，琢磨着我该如何加入对话或者说点什么。但当时我的外语水平实在太匮乏了。要融入社交生活真的很困难。但随着我对人们逐渐了解，我的语言技能也有所提高，在我呆在那里的那一年的时间里，我的语言技能有了很大的进步。
Many of us spend sleepless nights worrying about what others think of us. But the reflections we see of ourselves in the eyes of others are often distorted. We misread interactions, overthink our own insecurities. We fail to notice what other people actually notice about us. Erika Boothby and her colleague studied the psychological mechanisms behind these social illusions. Erica, you lived in Italy as a high school exchange student. Did you speak Italian? So I didn't speak Italian really before I got there. I had taken just a quick kind of crash course in Italian, which was for traveling essentially. So I learned things like how to count to 10.
我开始意识到，别人对我的批判性想法其实并没有我自己对自己的批判那么多。我之前投射了太多的自我怀疑，并让自己陷入沮丧之中，但那些其实根本就不是他们脑海中的想法。是的，所以作为一个身处这种情境中的高中生，你为什么会把注意力集中在自己的不安全感上，或者集中在你试图学习和说意大利语时犯下的错误上，这是完全可以理解的。但当然，你周围的人可能在想：这是一个来自美国的聪明的年轻女孩，她正花时间和精力来学习我们的语言。当你的内心可能充满不安全感时，他们内心对你可能充满了钦佩。是的，我希望我当时能意识到这一点，
And I could say my name is Erica. I'm American. Maybe a couple other things. That was kind of the extent of it. And it was full immersion. So I was living with an Italian family, and I was going to Italian high school. And I felt pretty awkward because I couldn't really engage
但相反，是的，我很没有安全感，而且因为自己无法真正参与到这些对话中而感到尴尬，但我确实也认为，这种经历不仅适用于身处异国他乡的人，因为总的来说，我们的对话伙伴其实都相当宽容。人们根本不在乎你是否搞砸了，
in conversations with people. So even at home with the host family sitting around the dinner table, they would want to know about my day. I'd want to be able to tell them, but we just couldn't get there. And it was really challenging. And I found the same thing at school with my classmates. They'd all stand around and chat during the breaks.
或者你是否没有把每句话都说得完美无缺，这其实就是对话运作的方式，而且人们也是这样期望的。你目前在沃顿商学院教授一门谈判课程，并且要连着上两个90分钟的课时。所以你在短时间内连续做两次相同的讲座。当你在做这件事时，脑海中浮现的社交错觉是什么，埃里卡？在社交互动中往往会发生的一件事是，我们经常觉得我们的内部状态、我们的情绪、我们的想法似乎都展示在所有人面前供大家参观，并且我们认为人们在对我们做出评价时正在利用这些信息。这通常被称为“透明度错觉”。所以，是的，我教这门课，连续上两个课时。在第一节课上，我精力充沛。但到了第二场讲座时，
And I would kind of stand there awkwardly, trying to figure out how I could jump into the conversation or say something. But my talent was just so impoverished at the time. It was really hard to partake in social life. But as I kind of got to know people and my language skills improved, they improved a lot over the course of the year that I
我知道自己的精力开始有些枯竭了。因此我觉得我的第二堂课永远没有第一堂课好，因为我在拿它跟第一堂课作比较。那时我的精力更充沛。因此，在学期结束时，当我查看这两堂课的评分时，我总是感到惊讶，因为它们的评分竟然是一模一样的。
was there. I started to realize that people didn't have as many critical thoughts about me as I had about myself. I'd been projecting a lot of that and getting really down on myself, but those weren't really the thoughts they were having at all. Yeah, so it's totally understandable as a high school student in a situation like this, why you would be focused on your insecurities or the mistakes that you're making as you are trying to learn and speak Italian. But of course, the people who are around you are probably thinking, here's this bright young girl from the United States who's taking the time and trouble to learn our language. And they're probably filled with admiration for you, even as you might be filled with insecurity. Yeah, I wish I'd realized that at the time,
所以这正好说明，从内部来看，当我试图想象别人是如何评价我时，我使用了所有他们并没有使用的比较，对吧？我累了，第二次讲课时没那么妙语连珠了，但当然我的第二堂课并不等于我的第一堂课。因此对他们来说，我的讲座看起来完全没问题。所以我认为我们在对话中也做了完全相同的事情。因此，当我们向人们讲述一个故事，或者向别人总结我们在工作
but instead, yeah, I was very insecure and I felt awkward that I couldn't really engage in these conversations, but I do think also that this experience doesn't just apply to people in a foreign country because in general, our conversation partners are pretty charitable. People don't really care if you mess up
中正在进行的一个项目时，你知道，我们知道里面所有的微小缺陷，知道我们说错的话，或者我们上次描述得更好时的话，但我们的对话伙伴并没有像我们那样多的比较对象。因此，他们的看法与我们截然不同。埃里卡做过实验，确切地揭示了人们对彼此的注意程度到底有多高。在其中一项研究中，她让志愿者穿上一件衬衫去见另一个人。其中的玄机是什么呢？
or if you don't say everything perfectly, that's kind of just how conversation works and people expect it. You currently teach a negotiation's course at Wharton and you have two 90 minute sections back to back. So you're giving the same lecture twice with very little time in between. What is the social illusion that goes through your head
这件衬衫的前面印着巴勃罗·埃斯科巴的照片——臭名昭著的哥伦比亚大毒枭，他曾制造了数十起谋杀案。我们把人请来，把实验室当作候诊室来对待，基本上改造了它，我们每次让两名参与者进来，他们在这张大桌子对面相对而坐，其中一个人穿着这件巴勃罗·埃斯科巴的衬衫，而另一个人在不知情的情况下，被指派为我们的观察员。然后事后，我们测量了那个观察员对另一个人注意和思考了多少，比如他们的外表、关于他们的任何事情。
as you do this, Erica? One thing that tends to happen in social interactions is that we often feel like our internal states, our emotions, our thoughts, our kind of on display for everyone to see, and we think that people are using that information when they're forming their evaluations of us. And this is something that is often called the illusion of transparency. And so yeah, I teach this course, two sections back to back. And in the first section, I am full of energy. But by the second lecture,
并且我们问穿巴勃罗·埃斯科巴衬衫的那个人，他们觉得另一个人对他们的注意力集中了多少。我想象大多数人都会认为对方敏锐地意识到了他们身上印着一个毒枭的照片。事实确实如此吗？没有，穿衬衫的人自我意识过强了，但从另一个人的角度来看，
I know that I'm starting to get a little depleted. And so I feel like my second class is never as good as the first class because I'm comparing it to the first class. And I had more energy then. And so at the end of the semester, I'm always surprised when I looked at my ratings for the two classes, and they are identical.
那只不过是他们碰巧穿的衣服罢了。因此，穿巴勃罗·埃斯科巴衬衫的人高估了外界对他们衬衫的注意力，因为那是他们高度关注的事情。但其他人其实在关注关于这个人的各种其他事情。你知道，比如他们在做什么，他们看手机了吗？他们看起来像刚从健身房出来吗？我不知道，不管是什么想法，但他们绝对没有专门关注
And so this just goes to show from the inside when I'm trying to imagine how other people are evaluating me, I'm using all these comparisons that they're not using, right? I'm tired, I wasn't as witty the second time, but of course my second class wasn't at my first class. And so to them, my lecture seems perfectly fine. And so I think we do the same exact thing in conversations. So when we tell people a story or we give people a summary of a project we're working on,
那件衬衫。所以，当我们思考与他人的互动时，埃里卡，我们往往把注意力集中在关于我们自己的非常微小的细节上，比如我们的发型、我们穿的衣服或者衬衫上的图片，而实际上其他人根本不是在这个微观层面上审视我们的。你能谈谈我们研究中发现的那些社交错觉是如何产生的吗？因为人们并没有用我们审视自己时那种精细的颗粒度来评价我们。当我们关注某件事并且对此感到焦虑时，就像你说的，
at work, you know, we know all the little flaws and the things we say or the things that we said better last time we describe them, but our conversation partners don't have as much to compare to as we do. And so they're seeing it totally differently. Erica has conducted experiments that reveal exactly how much people notice about one another. In one study, she had volunteers put on a shirt and go to meet another person. The catch?
我剪了个新发型，现在这就是为什么我只注意到我的头发感觉太短了，别人肯定一眼就能看出来，但实际上，别人根本没有注意到我们身上的那个特定细节，对吧？也就是我们碰巧关注或感到不自在的事情，但这并不意味着人们没有以其他方式关注我们，或者对我们产生其他想法。
The shirt had a photo in the front of Pablo Escobar, the infamous Colombian drug lord responsible for dozens of murders. We brought people in, we treated the lab like a waiting room, we basically converted it, and we had two participants come in at a time, they sat across from one another at this large table, and one person had on this Pablo Escobar shirt, and the other person was just without them knowing it, they were assigned to be our observer. And then afterward, we measured how much that observer had been noticing and thinking about the other person, what they looked like, anything about them.
我怀疑我们在评价别人时也是如此。当我们评价一个初次见面的人时，我们其实是在试图对他们是谁有一个整体的印象。我能和这个人相处吗？我们并没有用极高的颗粒度去审视他们。完全正确。我认为这确实切中了某种深刻的真理。所以我们只是试图弄清楚对方是敌是友。我们在一个很高的层面上判断。我们会想：他们会伤害我们吗？还是他们会成为我们的朋友？他们看起来像个足够好的人吗？也许我可以信任他们？然而，当我们担心被评判或者当我们处于另一端时，我们的思考
And we asked the person wearing the Paul Leskbar shirt, how much attention they thought the other person was paying to them. I'm imagining that most of them would believe that the other person is keenly aware that they're wearing a photo of a drug kingpin. Was that in fact what happened? No, the person wearing the shirt's very self-conscious, but from the other person's perspective,
停留在微观层面，纠结于我们是不是说错了什么话。而这根本不是我们被评判的标准。对吧。你知道，我想起了几年前发生的这样一件事：英国广播公司（BBC）正在对一位美国教授进行关于韩国政治的现场直播采访。我不知道你有没有看过这个，埃里卡，但这位教授看起来非常严肃，正在解释为什么弹劾韩国总统是一件好事。我其实为韩国人感到挺骄傲的。
that was just whatever they happened to be wearing. And so, people who were wearing the public escapade shirt overestimated how much tension was on their shirt because that was a thing that they were hyper-focused on. But people were paying attention to all kinds of other things about the person. You know, like, what they were doing, did they go on their phone? Did they look like they just came from the gym? I don't know, whatever the thoughts were, but they were not paying attention
我不是故意要显得居高临下，但我在这里已经住了十年了。这可能是我在这里生活过的最好的一天。我其实对他们完成这一步的方式印象深刻。然后就在他说话的时候，他梳着小辫的小女儿蹦蹦跳跳地跑进了他的书房，教授试图保持镇定并将她推开。如果他们真的这样做，我会感到惊讶。
to the shirt specifically. So when we think about the interactions that we have with other people, Erica, we're often focused on the very minute things about ourselves, how our hair looks or the clothes we are wearing or the picture on our shirt, and other people in fact are not taking us in at this micro level. Can you talk about some of the illusions that we use to study coming about because people are not evaluating us with the granularity with which we are evaluating ourselves? When we're paying attention to something and we're concerned about it, like you said,
请原谅我。接着一个婴儿用那种婴儿学步车摇摇晃晃地滑了进来，后面跟着一个四肢着地爬行的女人，她试图把两个孩子都拖出房间，而教授则继续着他的分析。现在他的孩子们在背景里放声大哭。我觉得在疫情期间，我们所有人都曾以这样或那样的形式经历过这种时刻，在某种程度上，我们的现实生活闯入了我们试图在别人面前树立的形象中。但我觉得这暴露出为了展现某种特定形象，
I got a new haircut, now that's why I'm paying attention to my hair feels so short, I must be obvious to other people, but in reality, people aren't noticing that specific thing about us, right? The thing that we happen to be focused on or self-conscious about, but that doesn't mean that people aren't paying attention to us in other ways or having other thoughts about us.
我们付出了多大的努力。并在某种程度上，暴露了我们对“如果别人能简单地看到真实的我们，将会发生什么”的恐惧。是的，这是一个很好的例子。我认为这千真万确。我们所有人都非常关切形象管理。我们希望人们以某种特定的光环来看待我们。从某种意义上说，这其实没那么重要，因为我认为人们对我们的
I suspect this is true of us in terms of our evaluations of others. When we're evaluating someone we meet for the first time, we are really trying to get a global impression of who they are. Will I be able to get along with this person? We're not looking at them with great granularity. Exactly. I think that really captures a really deep truth. And so we're trying to just figure out friend or foe. We're at a high level. We're like, are they going to hurt us? Or are they going to be our friends? Do they seem like a nice enough person? Maybe can I trust them? Whereas when we're worried about being judged or when we're on the other side, we're thinking
宽容度远超我们的预期。他们会为那些事情找借口。它们让我们显得更有共鸣。因此我认为我们之所以会担心，是因为我们对自己在别人面前想呈现的形象有着某种愿景。但在现实中，我们其实完全可以稍微更做自己一点。
at the micro level in terms of did we say something wrong? And that's really not what we're being judged on. Right. You know, I'm reminded of this incident a few years ago, the BBC was doing a live interview about South Korean politics with an American professor. I don't know if you've seen this, Erica, but the professor was looking very serious and explaining why the impeachment of the South Korean president was a good thing. I'm actually quite proud of the Koreans.
因此，我们探讨了人们如何高估别人对自己的批判、以及如何高估别人会严厉批判自己的不同方式。我想放一段关于一个略微不同概念的电影剪辑。这是来自《哈利·波特与魔法石》。哈利和他的挚友罗恩在霍格沃茨学校拆圣诞礼物，哈利发现自己收到了一件神秘的礼物。这是什么？某种斗篷。好吧，让我们看看把它穿上。哇！我的身体不见了！我知道那是什么。那是隐形斗篷。我隐形了。
I don't mean to sound kind of sending, but I've been living here for 10 years. This is probably the best day I've actually lived here. I'm actually quite impressed at how they've done this. And then he was talking, his young daughter with pigtails bounces into his office and the professor tries to maintain his composure and push her away. I would be surprised if they do.
所以事实证明，埃里卡，拥有隐形斗篷的不只是巫师。所以你曾经做过一项研究，你在自助餐厅里调查人们，询问他们观察别人有多少，以及他们觉得别人观察自己有多少。你发现了什么？我们发现，人们认为自己观察别人的次数，远多于他们自己被别人观察的次数。所以几乎就像是人们觉得自己是隐形的，但他们可以看穿别人身上穿的隐形斗篷。完全正确，完全正确。埃里卡提到了一个现实生活中的例子。
The pardon me. And then a baby paddles in on one of those baby walkers, followed by a woman who's crawling on all fours trying to drag both kids out of the room and the professor keeps going on with his analysis. Now his kids are wailing in the background. And I feel like all of us have been there in one form or another during the pandemic where our real lives in some ways have intruded on the impression that we're trying to create on others. But I feel it reveals the lengths we go to present a certain
2017年，美国总统唐纳德·特朗普的两名律师正在华盛顿特区市中心的一家餐厅吃午餐。他们当时正在讨论严肃的国家机密。这就是泰·科布（Ty Cobb）和约翰·道德（John Dowd）在华盛顿特区市中心这个繁忙的户外露台上见面吃午餐的时候。所以科布，提醒大家一下，是负责协调白宫对穆勒调查回应的律师，他们当时正在调查特朗普涉嫌与俄罗斯的纠缠。而道德是特朗普在此次调查中的首席外部律师，两人在这次午餐中讨论了非常敏感的信息。
impression of ourselves. And in some ways, our fears of what would happen if other people could simply see us as we are. Yeah, that's a great example. I think it's so true. We're all very concerned about impression management. We want people to see us in a certain light. And in some ways, it doesn't matter all that much because I think people are much more
所以他们谈论了正在进行的调查，谈论了一些关于贾里德·库什纳的事情，这些都是他们认为自己是在私下里、仅在彼此之间讨论的事情。当然，当时《纽约时报》的一位记者碰巧坐在隔壁桌。就这位记者而言，这两个男人的周围并没有隐形斗篷。没错，他们绝对没有。所以这位记者实际上在推特上发布了一张这两位律师交谈的照片，并配上了这样一段文字：
charitable toward us than we expect. They kind of explain away those things. They make us relatable. And so I think we can be worried because we have some vision of how we want to come off to other people. But in reality, we could probably stand to be a little bit more just ourselves.
这是泰·科布和约翰·道德在华盛顿特区BLT Steak餐厅大声而随性地讨论俄罗斯调查细节的照片。嗯，我就坐在隔壁桌。于是我接着多点了几个冰茶，旁听了这场信息量极大的谈话。嗯，埃里卡，你觉得为什么会发生这种事？你认为是什么解释了这样一个事实：我们身上几乎存在着这种双重的、相互矛盾的社交错觉？一方面，我们
So we've looked at different ways people overestimate how others will judge them and judge them harshly. I want to play you a movie clip about it slightly different idea. This is from Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone. Harry and his best friend Ron are opening Christmas presents at Hogwarts school and Harry finds he has received a mysterious gift. Why is it? Some kind of cloak. Well, let's see them put it on. Woah! My body's gone! I know what that is. That's an invisibility cloak. I'm invisible.
我们已经探讨了人们如何高估他人对自己的评判及严厉程度的不同方式。我想放一段关于稍微不同想法的电影剪辑给你听。这是出自《哈利·波特与魔法石》。哈利和他的挚友罗恩在霍格沃茨魔法学校拆圣诞礼物，哈利发现自己收到了一件神秘的礼物。这是什么？某种斗篷。好吧，让我们看他们穿上它。哇！我的身体不见了！我知道那是什么。那是隐形斗篷。我隐身了。
So it turns out Erica, it's not just wizards who own invisibility cloaks. So you once ran a study where you surveyed people in a cafeteria and asked them how much they were watching other people and how much they thought other people were watching them. What did you find? We found that people thought that they were observing others far more than they themselves were being observed. So it's almost like people felt like they were invisible, but they could pierce the invisibility cloaks that other people were wearing. Exactly, exactly. Erica mentions a real life example of this.
所以事实证明，埃丽卡，不仅仅是巫师才拥有隐形斗篷。你曾经做过一项研究，你在自助餐厅里调查了人们，询问他们观察别人有多少，以及他们认为别人观察他们有多少。你发现了什么？我们发现，人们认为自己观察别人的次数，远远超过了他们自己被观察的次数。所以这几乎就像是人们觉得自己是隐形的，但他们可以穿透别人身上穿的隐形斗篷。没错，完全正确。埃丽卡提到了一个这方面的现实生活例子。
In 2017, two of President Donald Trump's lawyers were having lunch at a restaurant in downtown Washington DC. They were discussing serious matters of state. This is when Thai Cobb and John Dowd met for lunch at this busy outdoor patio in downtown Washington DC. So Cobb, just to remind everyone, was the lawyer in charge of coordinating the White House's responses to the Mueller investigation and they were looking at a Trump's alleged in Tangleman's with Russia. And Dad was Trump's lead outside attorney in the investigation and the two of them were discussing very sensitive information at this lunch.
2017年，时任美国总统唐纳德·特朗普的两名律师在华盛顿特区市中心的一家餐馆吃午饭。他们当时在讨论严肃的国家大事。这是泰·科布和约翰·道德在华盛顿特区市中心这个繁忙的户外露台上共进午餐的时候。所以提醒大家一下，科布是负责协调白宫对穆勒调查回应的律师，他们当时在调查特朗普据称与俄罗斯的纠葛。而道德是特朗普在这项调查中的首席外部律师，他们两人在这次午餐中讨论了非常敏感的信息。
So they talked about the ongoing investigation, some things about Jared Kushner, and these were all things they thought that they were discussing privately just amongst themselves. And of course there was a reporter from the New York Times who happened to be sitting at the next table. And as far as that reporter was concerned, the two men did not have an invisibility cloak around them. That's right, they definitely did not. So this reporter actually posted a photo on Twitter of the two attorneys talking, along with the caption,
所以他们谈到了正在进行的调查，关于贾里德·库什纳的一些事情，这些都是他们认为自己只是在私下里讨论的事情。当然，当时《纽约时报》的一位记者恰好坐在隔壁桌。就那位记者而言，这两个人周围并没有隐形斗篷。没错，他们绝对没有。所以这位记者实际上在推特上发布了一张这两位律师交谈的照片，并配上了说明，
here's a photo of Ty Cobb and John Dowd, casually and loudly, discussing details of Russian investigation at BLT State DC. Well, I said it next table. And so I proceeded to order a few more iced teas and listen in on this very revealing conversation. Well, why do you think this happens, Erica? And what do you think explains the fact that we have almost these dual and conflicting sort of social illusions? On the one hand, we
这是泰·科布和约翰·道德在华盛顿特区BLT Steak餐厅随意且大声地讨论俄罗斯调查细节的照片。嗯，我就坐在隔壁桌。于是我接着点了更多的冰茶，并偷听了这个非常具有揭露性的对话。嗯，你认为为什么会发生这种事，埃丽卡？你认为是什么解释了这样一个事实：我们几乎拥有这种双重且冲突的社会错觉？一方面，我们
believe that people are judging us harshly and perhaps being overly observant of our flaws. And on the other, almost simultaneously, we believe that we have a cloak around us that other people cannot see through. Yeah, so I am very interested in cloak around us that other people cannot see through. Yeah, so I am very interested in the psychology of what makes us so oblivious to the fact that these guys could be sitting and talking about sensitive information, not realism, they're being observed, and not to sound conspiratorial, not like you're watched all the time, but I think the point is, we can get into a mode where we are the people watchers, right? We're observing other people, we're looking around. I mean, just think about how much you do this, pretty much anytime you're in a public place.
坚信别人对我们严加评判，或许对我们的缺点观察入微。而另一方面，几乎同时，我们又坚信自己身上披着一件别人无法看透的斗篷。是的，所以我对这种现象非常感兴趣：为什么我们对这样一个事实如此浑然不觉——这些人可能正坐在一起谈论敏感信息，这不是现实主义，他们正在被观察，这听听并不是说有什么阴谋论，好像你无时无刻不在被人监视，但我想重点是，我们会进入一种模式，即我们成为了观察他人的人，对吧？我们在观察其他人，我们在四处张望。我的意思是，想想你在公众场合时有多少次是这样的，几乎任何时候你在公共场所都是如此。
And the reality is that all the time is that we're doing this, other people are also doing it toward us. They're watching us. And this is something that happened to me, you know me early on as I was starting to think about the invisibility coalition, but just sitting in a cafe and I'll be working and then periodically I'll look up, I'll gaze around the room. And everyone I see seems to be diligently also working, like they're focused on their laptop, or they're talking to someone else. But then what I know now, based on my research,
而现实是，在我们这样做的同时，其他人也一直在对我们做同样的事情。他们在注视着我们。这曾发生在我身上，你知道的，早在我开始思考“隐形联合会”的时候，我就坐在咖啡馆里工作，然后我会时不时地抬头，环顾房间。我看到的每个人似乎都在埋头苦干，就像他们专注于自己的笔记本电脑，或者在和别人交谈。但现在根据我的研究我所了解的是，
is that as soon as I turn my attention back to my computer, they're doing the same thing toward me, right? They're glancing at me. And so now I can't unknow that. This is something that I'm now much, much more aware of. Yeah. Do I remember correctly that you runs around an experiment where you had people come and sit in a waiting room, but the waiting room in fact was not a waiting room. It was actually the scene of the study that you were running and you were trying to measure the same exact phenomenon that we've been talking about. Right, and what's nice is there were two people there and we knew what they were doing
一旦我把注意力转回电脑上，他们也在对我做同样的事情，对吧？他们在偷看我。所以现在我无法“不知道”这一点了。这是我现在意识得越来越多、越来越深的一点。是的。我没记错的话，你做过一个实验：你让人们来一个候诊室坐着，但这个候诊室实际上并不是候诊室。它其实就是你正在进行的实验的现场，你试图衡量我们一直在谈论的那个确切现象。没错，好在现场有两个人，我们知道他们在彼此附近时的行为。
while they were in each other's vicinity. And what we find is that people felt like they were the ones watching the other person. And they didn't feel like the other person was watching them. And it's actually just really hard to catch people watching you, which is part of the reason we have this, we see this effect.
我们发现，人们觉得自己才是那个在观察对方的人。他们并不觉得对方在观察自己。而实际上，要抓到别人在看你真的很难，这也是我们看到这种效应的部分原因。
So vision scientists call this gase deflection. When we're looking at someone and watching them, we usually try to disguise it. But that means that the people who are looking at you are also trying to hide that fact. So it's very hard for us to gather evidence that we're being watched, but when, as soon as we're not watching them,
所以视觉科学家称之为“视线偏转”。当我们看着某人并观察他们时，我们通常会试图掩饰。但这意味着那些看着你的人也同样在试图隐藏这一事实。因此，我们很难搜集到自己正在被注视的证据，但一旦我们没有看着他们时，
they're watching us. Yeah. So it seems to me that you're telling me that in different ways, we can both overestimate and underestimate the ways in which people notice us. Is there a tension between those two positions? I mean, how can both overestimate and underestimate the ways in which people notice us. Is there a tension between those two positions? I mean, how can those two illusions
他们就在看着我们。是的。在我看来，你的意思是，在不同的方面，我们既会高估也会低估人们注意到我们的方式。这两种立场之间是否存在某种张力？我的意思是，怎么可能……怎么可能同时高估和低估人们注意到我们的方式？这两种错觉怎么可能
be happening simultaneously? Yeah, I mean, it's a good question. I think we can get into thinking that we are the ones kind of observing other people. And this is especially when we're not interacting with them directly. In that case, we often feel like we're the ones watching other people.
同时发生呢？是的，我的意思是，这是一个好问题。我想我们会陷入这样一种思维：认为我们是那种在观察他人的人。尤其是在我们没有与他们直接互动的时候。在这种情况下，我们常常觉得自己才是观察别人的人。
But then when we're interacting with people, we're talking to them. Our critical voice turns on and we get more self-conscious, I think, and more concerned about the way that we're coming off to other people. And this can happen also, you know, kind of going back to the Pablo Escobar shirt, if people are wearing something that they are self-conscious about or feel weird about, that will also cause them to think someone is paying more attention to it. So we've talked a lot about our social interactions, but sometimes these social interactions are also being played out in memory.
但当我们与人互动、和他们交谈时，我们的批判性声音就会开启，我想我们会变得更加自我意识过剩，更加在意自己在别人眼中的形象。这种情况也会发生，你知道的，回到那件巴勃罗·埃斯科瓦尔的衬衫，如果人们穿了一件让他们感到自我意识过剩或觉得奇怪的衣服，这也同样会让他们觉得别人在上面倾注了更多的注意力。所以我们已经聊了很多关于社交互动的内容，但有时这些社交互动也会在记忆中重演。
So we think back to conversations, what we said, what someone else said, and one of the illusions that you've studied is that we think a lot about other people a lot, and what they said, we replay conversations in our minds, but we don't assume that other people are doing the same thing. So exactly the same way that we believe that we're observant of other people, but other people are not observing us. We also think about other people a lot more
所以我们会回想之前的对话、我们说过的话、别人说过的话，而你研究过的其中一种错觉是，我们认为自己想了很多关于别人的事，想了很多他们说的话，我们在脑海中重播对话，但我们却不认为别人也会做同样的事情。所以，正如我们坚信自己善于观察他人，而别人没有观察我们一样，我们想别人的程度，其实也远远超出
than we realize that they are thinking of us. Can you talk about that phenomenon? Right, so we spend a lot of time in conversations in daily life, and we also spend a lot of time more than we realize that they are thinking of us. Can you talk about that phenomenon? Right. So we spend a lot of time in conversations in daily life, and we also spend a lot of time thinking about our conversations after they've taken place. So we think about the advice someone gave us, or maybe a funny story they told us, and we replay those moments.
我们所意识到的他们想我们的程度。你能谈谈这种现象吗？没错，我们在日常生活中的对话中花费了大量时间，而且我们在对话结束后思考对话内容的时间，也远比我们意识到的他们想我们的程度要多。你能谈谈这种现象吗？没错。我们在日常生活中的对话中花费了大量时间，并且在对话结束后，我们也会花大量时间思考这些对话。所以我们会去想别人给我们的建议，或者他们给我们讲的一个有趣的故事，我们在脑海中不断重播这些时刻。
We remember them. We relive them. I think it's really clear to us when we're thinking about other people after we've interacted. But what we find is that people systematically underestimate how much they remain on the other people's mind after their conversation. Because they don't tell us, right?
我们记住它们。我们重温它们。我想在我们互动之后回想其他人时，这一点对我们来说真的很清晰。但我们发现，人们系统性地低估了自己在对话结束后留在对方心里的分量。因为他们没有告诉我们，对吧？
And just like we don't tell them, right? And this sort of just perpetuates this illusion. But I think we've looked at this to see kind of what some implications are in some specific context. So in one line of work, we looked at arguments. So arguments between friends or significant others. And we asked people how much they thought about the argument since it happened and how much they had replayed parts of their mind.
就像我们也没有告诉他们一样，对吧？这种现象就这样延续了这种错觉。但我认为我们研究过这一点，以了解它在某些特定背景下的一些影响。比如在其中一个研究方向中，我们研究了争吵。也就是朋友之间或重要另一半之间的争吵。我们询问人们，自从争吵发生后，他们想了多少次这场争吵，以及他们在脑海中重播了多少次其中的片段。
And also how much they thought their counterpart had. And again, we found people believe they were the ones thinking about the argument more. And if you're the one, you know, thinking about the argument, ruminating on it, concerned about it, but you think your partner is doing that much less, you know, that is going to make you feel a certain way, probably not a great way. And it affects your beliefs about how likely it is that your partner wants to reconcile or make up with you. You know, Erica, I spoke recently with the psychologist Emily Pronen. She's going to be featured in next weeks, mind reading 2.0 episode. And one of the things she studies is how when, you know, when we think about our own minds, we have access to all this information, you know,
还有他们认为对方想了多少。同样，我们发现人们坚信自己才是那个更多地去想这场争吵的人。如果你是那个一直在想这场争吵、反复琢磨、忧心忡忡的人，但你觉得你的伴侣想得要少得多，你知道的，这会让你产生某种感受，可能不是什么好感受。这会影响你对伴侣想要与你和解或重修旧好的可能性的看法。你知道，埃丽卡，我最近和心理学家埃米·普罗嫩（Emily Pronen）交谈过。她将成为下周“读心术 2.0”节目的特邀嘉宾。她研究的其中一个课题是，当我们在思考自己的内心时，我们能够获取所有这些信息，你知道的，
we're aware of our thoughts, our feelings, our hopes, our intentions. But then when we talk to others, we have a much more limited understanding of what's going on inside their heads. And that's because, of course, we're not inside their minds. How does the space of gap and perception shape the social illusions that you study? Yeah, I think it's a huge part of it. What we call the availability or accessibility of thoughts, right? And our own thoughts are hugely available and accessible to us.
我们清楚自己的思想、感受、希望和意图。但当我们与他人交谈时，我们对他们脑海中正在发生的事情的理解要有限得多。这是因为，当然，我们并不在他们的脑海里。这种感知上的差距和空间是如何塑造你所研究的社会错觉的？是的，我认为这是其中非常巨大的一部分。这就是我们所说的思维的“可用性”或“可及性”，对吧？我们自己的想法对我们来说是极其可用和可及的。
They're very salient. They come to mind, but we don't really have access to the inner workings of other people's minds. And so this is a huge problem that contributes to these illusions. The research of Michael Thomas-Sello and his colleagues recreated your liking gap experiment with children between the ages of four and 11. The researchers paired the kids up and asked them to build a tower together and then they asked each child,
它们非常显眼。它们会浮现于脑海，但我们实际上无法进入他人内心的运作机制。所以这是一个巨大的问题，正是它促成了这些错觉。迈克尔·托马斯-塞洛（Michael Thomas-Sello）及其同事的研究与四到十一岁的儿童一起重现了你们的“喜爱度差距”实验。研究人员把孩子们配对，让他们一起搭建一座塔，然后他们问每个孩子：
how much do you like the other boy or girl? How much would you like to be their friend? Do you remember this experiment, Erica, and what they found? Yeah, so in this study, yeah, they looked at kids age four through 11 and what they've found is actually that the legging gap does not exist in four-year-olds and it emerges actually this kind of critical period around age five, which is when young children are becoming more concerned with their
你有多喜欢另一个男孩或女孩？你有多想成为他们的朋友？埃丽卡，你还记得这个实验以及他们的发现吗？是的，在这项研究中，他们观察了4到11岁的儿童，他们发现实际上4岁的孩子并不存在喜爱度差距，这种差距在5岁左右的一个关键时期开始出现，此时年幼的儿童开始更加关注自己的
reputations and the impressions that they make on other people. And then what's interesting is it also increases all the way to age 11, which is the upper limit of the range that they were testing in this study. And so we don't actually have data on teams, but I think for teenagers, the liking gap is probably massive. And I'd be really interested in kind of seeing what happens across adulthood as people get older. So it seems as if self-consciousness in some ways
声誉以及他们在别人心目中的印象。有趣的是，这种差距一直增加到11岁，这也是他们在这项研究所测试的年龄范围的上限。因此，我们实际上没有关于青少年的数据，但我认为对于青少年来说，喜爱度差距可能非常巨大。而且我真的很想看看随着人们变老，在整个成年期会发生什么。所以看起来，在某些方面，自我意识
is sort of a crucial part of the liking gap and some of these social illusions, you know, very young children don't really care so much about what other people think of them and so you could see why maybe they have fewer of these illusions, but you know if someone who is 16, 17, and high school teenager is thinking about this a lot because their social interactions really matter and how well they fit into the group really, really matter. And you can see perhaps as we go get older, perhaps it starts to fade away again and we become more self-confident and perhaps less self-conscious. I mean, is that sort of the life cycle that you're seeing instead of the evolution of some
某种程度上是喜爱度差距以及其中一些社会错觉的关键部分，你知道的，非常年幼的儿童并不是很在乎别人怎么看他们，所以你可以明白为什么他们可能较少产生这些错觉，但是，如果一个16、17岁的高中青少年经常思考这个问题，因为他们的社交互动真的很重要，他们能否融入群体真的非常非常重要。而且你可以看出，随着我们年龄的增长，也许这种现象又开始消退，我们变得更加自信，也许自我意识不再那么过剩。我的意思是，这就是你所看到的生命周期，而不是某些
of these social illusions? That's my hypothesis. I don't have the data yet to speak to this, but that is what I would predict. We are collecting some data right now from people who are having conversations across generations. So we're collecting data from 30-somethings and 70-somethings. And we're having the 30-ish-year-olds talk to each other and the 70-ish-year-olds talk to each other. And then also these cross-generational conversations between them. And so I think what's interesting there is we can see if there are age effects such that younger people are showing a bigger liking gap than older people, does it occur also controlling for who
社会错觉的演变吗？这就是我的假设。我还没有相关的数据来证实这一点，但这正是我所预测的。我们现在正在收集一些数据，对象是正在进行跨代对话的人们。所以我们正在收集30多岁人群和70多岁人群的数据。我们让30岁左右的人互相交谈，70岁左右的人互相交谈。还有他们之间的跨代对话。所以我觉得有趣的是，我们可以看到是否存在年龄效应，比如年轻人是否比老年人表现出更大的喜爱度差距，这种差距是否在控制了
they're talking to, right? If they're talking to someone within their own age group or they're talking to someone of a different age group, whether that affects the liking gap as well. Do you think there are personality characteristics that make some of these social illusions either more likely or less likely? Yeah, so we have found that people who are more shy exhibit a larger liking gap and I would expect that social anxiety would as well. We haven't measured a lot of personality variables. We've only tested a few kind of in the early days, but I would be interested in doing that
他们和谁交谈的前提下依然存在？如果他们是和同龄人交谈，还是和不同年龄段的人交谈，这是否也会影响喜爱度差距。你认为是否存在某些人格特征，使得这些社会错觉更容易或更不容易发生呢？是的，我们发现比较害羞的人会表现出更大的喜爱度差距，我预计社交焦虑的人也会如此。我们并没有测量太多的人格变量。在早期我们只测试了少数几种，但我很有兴趣
in a larger sample to see what kinds of trends that we could find. And in the other direction, I might imagine that some, you know, a personality trait like narcissism, for example, might cause people to have the opposite conclusion. They actually believe that they're the center of everyone else's world when, in fact, they're not. Right. That would be interesting to look at as well. Do you think there's a functional reason why our brains produce some of the social illusions, Erica, why is it do you think that these exist in the mind? There definitely can be a function in terms of trying to improve for next time, especially with the laking gap. So if we're focused on our kind of self-critical thoughts, the times we fall short, the things
在更大的样本中进行测试，看看能发现什么样的趋势。而在另一个方向上，我可能会想象某些人格特质，比如自恋，可能会导致人们得出相反的结论。他们实际上相信自己是其他人世界的中心，而事实上并非如此。没错。这也是一个值得探讨的有趣方向。埃丽卡，你认为为什么我们的大脑会产生某些社会错觉，这里面是否存在某种功能上的原因？你认为为什么这些会存在于人类的思维中？从试图为下一次改进的角度来看，绝对是有功能的，尤其是对于喜爱度差距而言。因此，如果我们专注于那种自我批判的想法、我们表现不佳的时刻、
we said that we wish we hadn't, right, thinking about those counterfactuals and how we could have done better or we could improve for next time might actually help us. It might help us make a better impression next time or become a more savvy social actor. But I think it also has some pitfalls. So I think we kind of need to find the right balance there.
我们说过但希望没说过的话，对吧，去思考这些反事实以及我们本可以做得更好、或者为了下一次改进本可以怎么做，实际上可能会对我们有所帮助。它可能会帮助我们在下一次留下更好的印象，或者成为一个更精明老练的社交行动者。但我也认为它有一些陷阱。所以我认为我们需要在其中找到适当的平衡。
When we come back, how to become more aware of the social illusions that pervade our lives and how to fight them? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We all wonder what other people think of us, and we all want to be liked. But we often walk away from conversations with friends and strangers, worried that maybe we talk too much, or didn't say enough, or said the wrong thing.
广告过后，我们将探讨如何更加意识到弥漫在我们生活中的社会错觉，以及如何对抗它们。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain），我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们都想知道别人是怎么看我们的，我们都希望能讨人喜欢。但我们经常在与朋友和陌生人交谈后离开，担心自己是不是话说得太多，或者说得不够，又或者说错了话。
Some of us spend sleepless nights worrying about how social interactions unfolded. Psychologist Erika Boothby studies how a perception of our social worlds are like looking into a funhouse mirror. She calls these distortions social illusions. Recognizing these illusions for what they are is an important first step to seeing things more clearly. Yeah, being aware of it I think can help. And a lot of people have written me about the licking gap and said how much it resonates with them. I've had clinical psychologists tell me that now they tell their patients about it and it's helped them feel better just knowing that they're not alone. The other people feel
我们中的一些人甚至会彻夜难眠，担忧社交互动的进展。心理学家埃丽卡·布思比（Erika Boothby）研究了我们对社交世界的感知如何就像是在照哈哈镜。她将这些扭曲称之为“社会错觉”。认清这些错觉的本质，是更清晰地看待事物的重要第一步。是的，我认为意识到这一点会有所帮助。很多人写信给我谈到喜爱度差距，并表示这引起了他们强烈的共鸣。曾有临床心理学家告诉我，现在他们会把这个现象讲给患者听，仅仅是知道自己并不孤单，这就能帮助患者感觉好一些。其他人也
this way too. And that does seem to help. In addition to recognizing that these illusions exist, there are other techniques that can also help us to see our interactions with other people more clearly. Erika, when you first moved to Philadelphia to begin teaching at Wharton, you didn't know many people. So you made a coffee date with a friend of a friend. This was another young academic who was also new in town. And you were thrilled that you'd made a new friend. But then you didn't hear back from her.
会有这种感觉。这确实似乎有所帮助。除了认识到这些错觉的存在之外，还有其他技巧也能帮助我们更清晰地看待我们与他人的互动。埃丽卡，当你刚搬到费城开始在沃顿商学院教书时，你并不认识很多人。于是你和朋友的朋友约了喝咖啡。这是另一个同样刚到镇上的年轻学者。你很高兴自己交到了新朋友。但后来你没有收到她的回音。
How did your initial conversation go and what went through your mind when you didn't hear back? I really liked her. I could imagine becoming friends. Of course, I tried to contain my excitement and play it cool. And then, you know, a few days past, no word from her. I didn't get, you know, a text saying she enjoyed her conversation or anything following up. And so I just, I don't know, got a little worried. And I texted our mutual friend. I raved about what a great, interesting person she was. And I just said I wasn't sure how much she liked me,
你们最初的对话进展得怎么样？当你没有收到回复时，你心里在想什么？我很喜欢她。我可以想象我们成为朋友。当然，我试图克制自己的兴奋，表现得酷一点。然后，你知道的，几天过去了，她没有任何音讯。我没有收到诸如“她很享受我们的谈话”之类的短信或任何后续联系。所以我只是，我不知道，变得有点担心。我给我们的共同朋友发了短信。我大赞她是一个多么伟大、有趣的人，我只是说我不确定她究竟有多喜欢我，
or if she'd actually be interested in meeting up again. I felt like I'd been kind of rambling a lot in the conversation. I was nervous. The stakes felt kind of high. I didn't have any friends here. And so I wanted it to work out. But to my surprise, then my mutual friend wrote me back.
或者她是否真的有兴趣再次见面。我觉得自己在对话中好像一直在东拉西扯。我很紧张。感觉利害攸关。我在这里没有任何朋友。所以我希望事情能成。但令我惊讶的是，我的共同朋友回信了。
And she said, that's so funny. You both texted me the same thing about each other. You should just text her. And so there it was, victim to my own effect. I studied the LAKING GAP. And so oftentimes, I do try to check my self-critical voice and override it when I can. But for some reason in this moment,
她说：“太搞笑了。你们俩发给我的关于彼此的内容一模一样。你应该直接给她发信息。”就这样，我成了自己效应的受害者。我研究过喜爱度差距。所以很多时候，我确实会努力克制自己内心的批判声音，并在可能的时候去压制它。但不知为什么，在那一刻，
I really wasn't thinking like a scientist. I was just emotionally in the moment. But luckily, in this case, had our mutual friend to help set us straight. Otherwise, I'm just not sure we would have ever seen each other again, even though we both wanted to. I love the story, because it really shows how sometimes
我真的没有像个科学家一样思考。我只是完全处于当时的情绪中。但幸运的是，在这个案子里，我们有共同的朋友帮忙把我们拉回正轨。否则，我真不确定我们是否还会再见到彼此，尽管我们俩其实都想。我喜欢这个故事，因为它真正展示了有时
we need to turn to friends to family members, to therapists, to help us see reality more clearly. Exactly. I think it really helps in these cases to get an outside perspective. And I think intuitively many of us understand that this is valuable. I think what I take away from your work
我们需要向朋友、家人、治疗师求助，以帮助我们更清晰地看清现实。完全正确。我认为在这种情况下，获得一个外部视角真的很有帮助。而且我认为凭直觉，我们中的许多人也明白这是有价值的。我认为从你的工作中我汲取到的
really is that it's really important to do this systematically, not just at a point where you feel like something has gone wrong but to systematically invite third parties in to basically say what do you think is going on what do you see happening here because it's possible that they will see things differently than you do yeah i think that's exactly right there's a second powerful idea in addressing the social illusions i want to play you a clip from the TV show Ted Lasso, Erica. A woman is worried that a guy she's dating isn't as interested in her as she is in him.
真正重要的教训是，以系统化的方式做到这一点非常重要，而不仅仅是在你觉得事情出了问题的时候，而是要系统性地引入第三方进来，基本上问他们：“你觉得现在是什么情况？你看到这里发生了什么？”因为很有可能会看到和你不一样的东西。是的，我认为完全正确。在应对社会错觉时，还有一个强有力的第二个观点，我想给你放一段电视剧《泰德·拉索》（Ted Lasso）的片段，埃丽卡。一个女人担心她约会的男人对她并没有像她对他那样感兴趣。
She thinks he might be seeing other people and she confronts him. So the other day when he said you were too busy to take some back? Yeah, because I was busy. But you never told me what you were too busy with? Yeah, because I was busy. But you never told me what you were too busy with. Yeah, because it was private. Are you dating other people? It's okay if you are. It's just that I want to know, so that I don't look stupid. With yoga, okay?
她觉得他可能在跟别人约会，于是跟他当面对质。所以那天他说你太忙了，没空接电话？对啊，因为我很忙。但你从来没告诉我你到底在忙什么？对啊，因为我很忙。但你从来没告诉我你到底在忙什么。对啊，因为那是隐私。你在跟别人约会吗？如果是也没关系。我只是想知道，免得我看起来像个傻子。去练瑜伽，好吗？
I do yoga with a group of women in their 60s. They have no idea who I am. It's twice a week and it's really good for my call. Normally, I need to take it out. Erica, can you talk about the idea that sometimes a really effective way to find out what's happening in the minds of other people is to simply ask them? Yeah, I think this is a great example.
我和一群60多岁的女性一起练瑜伽。她们根本不知道我是谁。一周两次，对我的核心真的很有好处。通常我得把这个拿出来。埃丽卡，你能谈谈这样一种观点吗：有时弄清别人脑海中在想什么的一个真正有效的方法，就是直接去问他们？是的，这是一个极好的例子。
And it just shows what we're talking about in terms of impression management, right? He doesn't want to share where he really was, why he didn't text back, because that is embarrassing for him. But on the other flip side, for her, she really needed to know. And so, yeah, I think this is a great example of how effective it can be to sometimes just ask, but there's reasons that we don't, and sometimes it's well-founded, right? On the one hand, we don't want to pry or be pushy, and we think that if someone didn't tell us something, there's a reason for it, and we should kind of let them have that space.
这恰恰展示了我们一直在谈论的印象管理，对吧？他不想分享他真正去了哪里、为什么没有回信息，因为那对他来说很尴尬。但在另一面，对她而言，她真的需要知道。所以，是的，我认为这是一个很好的例子，说明有时候直接去问会有多么有效，但我们之所以不这么做是有原因的，有时这些原因也是有根据的，对吧？一方面，我们不想窥探或显得咄咄逼人，我们认为如果某人没有告诉我们某事，那是有原因的，我们应该给他们留出那个空间。
And on the other hand, as we don't ask people things directly because we're afraid of what the answer might be. I want to talk about a third way to dismantle some of these illusions. Can you talk about the importance of trying to pay less attention to ourselves, you know, our own fears, our anxieties, our needs, and more attention to the other person, what they actually are saying and doing. How can that potentially play a role in dismantling some of these solutions?
而在另一方面，我们不直接问别人事情是因为我们害怕答案会是什么。我想谈谈消除其中一些错觉的第三种方法。你能谈谈努力把更少注意力放在我们自己身上——你知道的，我们自己的恐惧、焦虑、需求，而把更多注意力放在另一个人身上，放在他们实际在说什么和做什么上，这有多么重要吗？这在消除其中一些错觉方面可能起到什么作用？
The research on social anxiety shows that if you go into a conversation with the goal of learning as much about your partner as possible, that that shifts your attention from being focused on your own thoughts and what you might be doing wrong, toward being focused on your conversation partner.
关于社交焦虑的研究表明，如果你带着尽可能多地了解你的搭档这一目标进入对话，这就会将你的注意力从专注于你自己的想法以及你可能做错了什么，转移到专注于你的对话伙伴身上。
And so, I try doing this myself. And a lot of the thoughts that normally fuel the liking gap, are concerns about what people think of us, just aren't there when I'm more focused on the other person. So in conversations you're actually asking yourself, stay focused on the other person, stay focused on what's happening in their mind, let me try and understand them a little better. Yeah, I think even thinking about it not as try to stay focused on them, but if you actually think about it as trying to be curious about them and interested in them, that is actually a better mental
所以，我自己也尝试过这样做。很多通常助长喜爱度差距的想法——也就是担心别人怎么看我们的忧虑——当我更加专注于另一个人时，它们就根本不存在了。所以在对话中，你实际上是在问自己：“保持对另一个人的关注，保持对他们脑海中正在发生的事情的关注，让我试着更好地理解他们。”是的，我想甚至不要把它想成“试着保持对他们的关注”，而是如果你实际上把它想成是“对他们感到好奇并对他们感兴趣”，这其实是一种更好的心理
strategy and it just gives you a different mindset altogether in the conversation. If you can kind of maintain your curiosity, ask them questions about themselves, ask them follow up questions, like that's really where you want to be, and that will help you get more immersed in the conversation and less focused on yourself. I remember reading a research study maybe about a year or so ago, which talked about sort of how much people underestimate the power of asking questions and conversations and how much they believe that a conversation is about, you know, making statements and offering their opinions and how much more they're in fact liked when, in fact, they ask questions of the other person, which speaks exactly to what you're just saying, Erika. Exactly.
策略，它会在对话中完全给你带来一种不同的心态。如果你能保持某种好奇心，问他们关于他们自己的问题，问他们后续的问题，这才是你真正想要达到的状态，这会帮助你更多地沉浸在对话中，而减少对自身的关注。我记得大约一年前左右读过一项研究，它讨论了人们在多大程度上低估了在对话中提问的力量，以及他们多大程度上认为对话就是发表声明和提出自己的观点，而当他们向另一个人提问时，他们实际上会更受欢迎，这正好契合了你刚才所说的，埃丽卡。完全正确。
I mean, it's a win-win because on the one hand, you're getting outside of your own head and your own self-critical thoughts, but also focusing on them, asking them questions, learning about them, makes them like you more. I want to talk about one other idea, Erica, and this is not so much about removing the social illusions as much as it's about preventing the social illusions from harming our relationships. You grew up near the ocean in Santa Cruz, California, and recently you've gone back to surf there. Can you tell me the story of the king of 38th Street, and what the story taught you about the power of compliments?
我的意思是，这是双赢的，因为一方面，你走出了自己的脑海和自我批判的想法，但另一方面，关注他们、向他们提问、了解他们，会让别人更喜欢你。埃丽卡，我想谈另一个观点，这与其说是为了消除社会错觉，不如说是为了防止社会错觉损害我们的关系。你在加利福尼亚州圣克鲁斯的海边长大，最近你又回去那里冲浪了。你能给我讲讲“38街之王”的故事，以及这个故事教会了你关于赞美力量的什么道理吗？
Yeah, so I got really addicted to surfing a couple of years ago, and I go to this spot at 38. It's just a great beginner wave, and I spend a lot of time there, especially early on just trying to figure out how to ride waves, how to pop up, which is just getting from laying down on the board just standing up. And there was this guy, he's an amazing surfer, he's always out there and he was always in exactly the right spot, catching all the best waves. And my friends and I privately call him the King of 38th. And he has no idea about that, of course.
是的，所以我在几年前迷上了冲浪，我去38街的那个地方。那是一个极好的初学者浪区，我在那里花了很多时间，尤其是一开始，只是试图弄清楚如何冲浪、如何起乘，也就是从趴在冲浪板上转为站立。那里有一个家伙，他是个令人惊叹的冲浪高手，他总是在那里，而且总是处于完全正确的位置，抓到所有最好的浪。我和我的朋友们私下里叫他“38街之王”。当然，他对此一无所知。
But I always keep an eye on him when I'm out there because he's so good, he's so fun to watch, and I can really learn a lot from him. And so one morning I was out in the water, it was me, the king, and just a handful of other people. And I was having one of the best days I'd ever had. Catching just about every way I paddled for getting these really long rides. And all of a sudden, I saw the king of 38 himself paddling up to me.
但我每次在水里时都会留意他，因为他太棒了，看他冲浪非常有意思，我真的能从他身上学到很多东西。所以有一天早上我在水里，当时只有我和“国王”以及另外少数几个人。那是我经历过的最好的一天之一。我划过去的几乎每一个浪都被我抓到了，滑行了很长很长一段距离。突然，我看到38街之王本人正朝我划过来。
And I thought, oh no, for sure, he's going to tell me that I had done something wrong. So the cardinal sin in surfing is dropping in on someone, which just means paddling into a wave when someone else is already on it. And I thought, for sure, I did something really dumb. I hadn't noticed, and he was about to lecture me. But instead, he actually smiled at me, told me that my positioning was perfect, and he'd noticed I just had a really nice natural style. And I was totally floored.
我想，哦不，毫无疑问，他肯定是来告诉我我做错了什么。因为冲浪的最大禁忌就是“插队”（dropping in），也就是在别人已经起乘在一个浪上时硬划进去。我想，我肯定做了什么非常蠢的事。我刚才没注意到，他这是要来训斥我。但相反，他对我笑了笑，告诉我我的站位堪称完美，并且他注意到我有一种非常漂亮自然的风格。我完全惊呆了。
I mean, this made my week. Absolutely, because the king himself had a notice me, B, he's seen that I was having a great day out there, and C, he bothered to come over and tell me about it. I mean, it was an amazing feeling. And what's interesting is that there's a million times I've noticed people doing things I really liked, but I usually kept those thoughts to myself. But after I got this compliment from the king of 38th, and knowing what I do now about compliments from my own research, I really try to make it a point to give them more compliments on the water
我的意思是，这让我一整周的心情都好极了。绝对如此，因为“国王”本人：A，注意到了我；B，他看到我在水里度过了美好的一天；C，他特意过来告诉我这件事。我的意思是，那种感觉太棒了。有趣的是，有无数次我注意到别人做了我非常喜欢的事情，但我通常把这些想法留给自己。但在我得到了38街之王的赞美之后，结合我从自己的研究中对赞美的了解，我真的开始刻意在水里多给别人一些赞美，
instead of just keeping those thoughts to myself and not telling anyone. And I've noticed that that makes a huge difference. I mean, people are always surprised when I compliment them out when we're surfing because these compliments are kind of rare. Even though we're all sitting there thinking, plenty of nice things about each other,
而不是把这些想法藏在心里谁也不告诉。我发现这带来了巨大的改变。我的意思是，每当我们在冲浪时我夸奖别人，他们总是会感到惊讶，因为这种赞美有点罕见。尽管我们所有人坐在那里都在心里
no one actually says what they're thinking. I'm wondering if one of the advantages of offering compliments is in fact, people are often worried that other people don't like them. In fact, their self-concept is that, other people don't like me as much as I like them. And when people give us compliments, in some ways, they are helping us to dismantle the liking gap.
想着彼此的很多好话，但没有人真正把心里想的话说出口。我在想，提供赞美的好处之一其实是，人们常常担心别人不喜欢他们。事实上，他们的自我概念是：别人不如我喜欢他们那样喜欢我。而当人们给我们赞美时，在某种程度上，他们正在帮助我们消除喜爱度差距。
So we see that someone actually is, does actually like us, is coming up to say something nice to us. It helps to compensate for this bias that we're carrying around inside our own heads. I definitely think that's true. And I also think that's why it's so surprising to us when we receive these compliments. Because we don't expect it, right?
所以我们看到，某人实际上确实喜欢我们，并走过来对我们说一些暖心的话。这有助于弥补我们脑海中一直背负着的这种偏见。我绝对觉得是这样的。而且我也认为这就是为什么当我们收到这些赞美时会感到如此惊讶。因为我们没有预料到，对吧？
We kind of expect the worst from people in a sense. We don't realize how charitable they are socially or how positively they already think about us. So when they do give us these compliments, it's kind of a window into what they're actually thinking. Erica Boothby is a psychologist at the University of Pennsylvania's Wharton School. Erica, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain.
从某种意义上说，我们对人抱有最坏的预期。我们没有意识到他们在社交上是多么慷慨，或者他们对我们的看法其实是多么积极。所以当他们确实给予我们这些赞美时，这就像是一扇了解他们真实想法的窗户。埃丽卡·布思比是宾夕法尼亚大学沃顿商学院的心理学家。埃丽卡，谢谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。
Thank you so much for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Laura Quarelle, Kristen Wong, Autumn Barnes, Ryan Katz, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung heroes this week are Marissa Morales and Hannah Stifle. Marissa and Hannah handle podcast merchandise at Stitcher and they recently helped us to launch our new online
非常感谢邀请我。本期《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、安妮·墨菲-保尔（Annie Murphy-Paul）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）、克里斯汀·王（Kristen Wong）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）和安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。我们本周的幕后英雄是玛丽萨·莫拉莱斯（Marissa Morales）和汉娜·斯蒂夫尔（Hannah Stifle）。玛丽萨和汉娜负责 Stitcher 的播客周边商品，她们最近帮助我们推出了《隐藏的大脑》全新在线
shop for Hidden Brain. Marissa and Hannah worked tirelessly to support podcast teams and they bring a creative, can-do approach to their jobs. You can see the fruits of their labor at shop.hiddenbrain.org. Thank you Marissa and thank you Hannah. Next week in our mind reading 2.0 series we look at a blind spot in the way we judge what's happening in other people's heads. There's the path that we use for self-judgment and there's the path that we use for judging others. And in my view, the path that we use for judging others is we look at their
商店。玛丽萨和汉娜为支持播客团队付出了不懈的努力，她们为工作带来了创造力与“志在必得”的态度。你可以在 shop.hiddenbrain.org 看到她们的劳动成果。谢谢玛丽萨，也谢谢汉娜。下周在我们的“读心术 2.0”系列节目中，我们将探讨人们在判断他人脑海中发生的事情时的一个盲点。有一条路径是我们用于自我判断的，还有一条路径是我们用于判断他人的。在我看来，我们用来判断他人的路径是观察他们的
actions. The path that we use for judging ourselves is we look inwards. If you like today's show, please be sure to share it with a couple of friends. While you're at it, pay those friends a compliment that you always thought, but never set out loud. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
行动。而我们用来判断自己的路径则是向内看。如果你喜欢今天的节目，请务必与几位朋友分享。顺便提一句，不妨对那些朋友送上一句你一直想说、却从未大声说出口的赞美。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们回头见。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。